[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اكله المنسف اكله تراثيه اردنيه واحنا
كردنيين بنفتخر انها همم فازت ضمن
الفلكلور العالمي لانها اكله لا غنى لنا
عنها اردنيين في افراحنا وافراحنا
ومناسباتنا الغاليه علينا ومش مجرد اكله
بس واحنا يعني لازم ناكلها في لها تاريخ
تاريخ يعني عريق مش من اليوم ولا من بكره
وبتمنى انه اصلا كل امه تعلمها لبناتها
لانها ما بدنا تراثنا هذا ينتشر من جيل
لجين لجميد الكركيه طبعا بنعمل من لبن
يجمد في طريقه ما في الشمس فيصير كرات
بيحطوه ايام طويله بعد ما اللبن الغنم
بحطوه في الشمس ليصير الكرات هاي كل مكان
ملحوق اقل كل مكان جوده اعلى
لما نيجي نسلق اللحمه ونحط لها المطيبات
ونحط معها معلقه سمن بلدي
ونسلقها فقط نصها القوم ضيفها على الجميد
بعد ما نمروا
نضيفها على اللحمه كم على اللبن تكمل
استوى مع اللحمه ناخذ نكهتين نكهه اللحمه
ونكهه اللبن
[موسيقى]
صدر المنسف اول شيء بناخذ خبز الشراك
بنفردوا على الرغيف من شربه في اللبن
بعدين بنحط الارز مرتبه فوق صدر المنسف
ومشيل قطع اللحم مرتبها اذا خروف كامل
بيكون الراس معه وبنحطه واذا قطع نحطه قطع
اللحمه نحط عليها الصنوبر اللوز وبرد نشرب
كمان طبقه لبن ونغطيه في رغيف من
خبز للشراك
[موسيقى]
هي اصلا من السنه الاكل في الايدين
بياكلوا بهيك بثلاث اصابع من كور هيك في
ايدينا بناخذ مع اللحم مع الخبز مع الرز
من كونه هيك في ايدينا بثلاث اصابع وقم
ناكله فا يعني ما شاء الله هي اكله جامعه
كل الجمال سواء في طريقه طبخها او في
اعدادها او باكل اكلها